[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 loisirs comme chaque jeudi
des sorties pour profiter de votre
week-end dans les yvelines et tout de
suite le sommaire de cette semaine une
édition anniversaire ce week-end débute
la foire de chatou un rendez-vous qui
fête sa 100e édition plus de 400
exposants sont attendus depuis le début
du mois de mars et poètes ont investi
saint quentin en yvelines une vingtaine
d'événements vous est proposé nous
ferons le point sur la programmation et
l'agenda complet de vos sorties au
programme des jeux du sport et une
exposition le 13 mars et le retour de la
traditionnelle foire de chatou une
édition un peu particulière puisque la
foire fête cette année sa 100e édition
plus de 400 exposants vous attendent et
pour l'occasion une série de tendre a
été créé en partenariat avec la poste
le rendez vous est donné sur l'île des
impressionnistes et de parrains de cette
année c'est le journaliste patrick
poivre d'arvor
on va changer de nom là les nouvelles
qui va dorénavant s'appeler allée pierre
davot c'est peu dire pierre davot ces
temps d un des piliers un des fondateurs
du syndicat du srd
on va remettre la médaille des
antiquaires à yves lecoq qui est lui est
un passionné de d'antiquités de chatou
voilà deux mâts blancs c'est tout
on défend un peu les gens qui se battent
pour le patrimoine et sur la
conservation du patrimoine
malgré le contexte sanitaire lié aux que
8,19 la foire est maintenue des
dispositions sont prises pour limiter la
participation du public à 1000 personnes
présentes simultanément dans l'ensemble
de la foi mais l'événement se tient
jusqu'au 22 mars prochain une soirée de
sport au profit d'une association ce
samedi 14 mars et la douzième nuit de la
gymnastique la ville de guyancourt la
gymnastique et la gymnastique rythmique
et sportive vous invite à deux
représentations 16 heures 30 et 20
heures
la recette sera intégralement reversée à
l'association boucher coeur
[Musique]
la 22e édition du printemps des poètes a
débuté le 3 mars l'occasion de célébrer
la poésie sous toutes ses formes
notamment à saint quentin en yvelines et
aux non pas avec aurélie ronge mon sort
mais naniwa chaque année en cette
manifestation nationale célèbre les mots
les verbes les idées pendant trois
semaines un rendez vous auquel
participent 50 ans ni been avec une
programmation éclectique aux quatre
coins du territoire
l'objectif de cette manifestation est
bien c'est mieux faire comprendre au
public ce qu'est ce genre littéraire
cette poésie c'est pas les petits
oiseaux c'est pas les nuages ses palais
ses pas les petites fleurs qui poussent
dans les dents les chances et c'est la
vie c'est le monde c'est c'est vous
c'est moi c'est tout ce qui se passe
dans le monde
les poètes parle de ce qui se passe en
syrie il parle de des changements
climatiques il parle d'amour
il parle de vie parle de mort il parle
de ce qui fait l'humain quoi et chaque
édition met en avant un thème en
particulier
oui alors c'est une thématique nationale
il y a deux ans c'était l'ardeur l'année
dernière la beauté et cette année est
bien un c'est le courage qui est célébré
le courage de dire le courage de lire de
fer ou encore le courage de vivre alors
au programme c'est jusqu'au 22 mars il
ya une vingtaine d'événements dont
quasiment toutes les villes de saint
quentin en yvelines où ils alors il y
aura des spectacles des séances de
lecture y aura même un bal un bal à bla
bla mais aussi aide des animations dans
les médiathèques a par exemple le
mercredi 18 mars le rhapsodes yves godin
vous attend à partir de 14h30 à la
médiathèque anatole-france attrape alors
pour info un rap sort des biens c'est un
artiste en grèce antique qui allait de
ville en ville à déclamer des oeuvres
rhapsodes cela veut dire celui qui coupe
les odes est justement donc le rhapsodes
yves godin est l'invité d'honneur de
cette 22e édition
je vais rencontrer des gens qui
utilisent qui fréquentent ces lieux et
par le biais de cette fréquentation va
peut-être moins mieux me familiariser
avec leur leur lecture leur vie de tous
les jours qui les amène à aller
dans ces lieux que je m'aime je fuyais
quand j'étais enfant tu vois jamais
vraiment jamais peur de cet
amoncellement savoir en quelque sorte
et bien sûr si vous voulez et bien en
savoir plus sur les temps forts de cette
22e édition
n'hésitez pas à les revoir le 7-8
culture de ce mardi 7 8 culture qui
était consacrée en grande partie au
printemps des poètes à saint quentin en
yvelines
et puis l'intégralité de la
programmation et est accessible sur le
site qui s'affiche en bas de votre écran
merci aux élus toutes les informations
sont données ne reste plus qu'à se
laisser tenter ce week-end de mars est
aussi le moment où débutent les
rencontres in cité pensée est piloté par
le théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
elle se déroule du 14 au 21 mars ces
rencontres s'intéresse cette année à la
ville de demain et ses défis on écoute
lionel masse et à le directeur du
théâtre c'est un thème qui inspire
beaucoup les artistes qui inspire
beaucoup les cinéastes si vous tapez
cinéma évident vous allez avoir trouvé
une liste de 3000 films qui va qui va
sortir
et puis c'est une problématique qui est
tellement tellement actuelle je crois
que ce qui nous a au départ quand quand
on a décidé de mettre en place et en
continu cité on se disait quels sont les
thèmes du quotidien qui peuvent être
creusée qui nous intéresse tous quand on
parle du temps voilà nos vies
s'inscrivent dans le temps lorsqu'on
parle de l'humain demain de la
convergence technologique en a tous un
smartphone lorsqu'on parle de
l'alimentation on est tous concernés et
lorsqu'on parle de la ville en est où on
sera bientôt 80 ou 85% de la population
mondiale à être concernée par par cette
question puisqu'on sera citadins et que
l'augmentation du nombre de citadins est
exponentielle depuis depuis un siècle
donc
voilà qu'est ce que kelly qu'elle dise
quelles sont les problématiques que
rencontrent les citadins que rencontre
la ville aujourd'hui ces rencontres ce
sont des représentations des tables
rondes des conférences mais aussi des
projections et parmi les films diffusés
il y appelait time réalisé par jacques
tati en 1967 on regarde un extrait
[Musique]
nous en parlions avec eux notre invité
la semaine dernière depuis ce jeudi 12
mars a débuté le festival électro chic
plusieurs jours de musique électro sur
l'agglomération de versailles grand parc
mais a noté que l'actualité a poussé
l'organisation à modifier la
programmation sont ainsi reporté le
concert de prequel prévue ce vendredi 13
mars au théâtre montansier et reporter
aussi la soirée allons de vélizy
initialement prévue ce samedi 14 mars
toutes les précisions sont à retrouver
sur la page facebook du festival autres
festivals sur saint quentin en yvelines
celui-ci se passe à magny les hameaux à
tout bout de champ rend cette année
hommage à boris vian et georges brassens
et célébrer la liberté la mémoire de mur
un festival qui se déroule jusqu'au 29
mars aux clayes-sous-bois ces charlots
qui fait son cinéma le célèbre
personnage inventé par charlie chaplin
est au coeur d'un festival de rendez
vous le samedi 14 mars à 16 heures 30 et
le dimanche 15 mars à 18 heures des
séances sont proposées aux enfants dès
l'âge de 4 ans trois courts métrages
sont projetés dont charlot policeman en
regardant extraits
[Musique]
du 14 au 22 mars et la 25e semaine de la
langue française et de la francophonie
de nombreux lieux y vino ont choisi d'y
participer et du côté de maisons
laffitte le château propose un jeu de
piste sans tout vous dévoiler les
équipes vous donne quelques éléments de
cette journée les images sont
cinématique de 2010 alors j'imagine que
la visite elle se commence dans cette
pièce
oui exactement on commence le jeu de
piste autour de ce tableau puisque le
gepeep tu vas être un jeu de piste
multisensorielle mai sur le thème de
l'eau dans cette pièce le jeu sera une
charade au château de maisons dix mots
vont être à trouver par le public des
mots autour de l'eau à découvrir dans
une enquête sensorielle sur les traces
de louis xiv à travers les salles du
château nous bien évidemment à travers
nos décors à travers nos peintures à
travers un autre jardin voilà à travers
un certain nombre d'éléments nous avons
un lien direct avec l'eau sachant qu
aussi dans le château de maisons il y
avait l'eau courante ce qui n'était
quand même pas fréquent à l'époque
donc là on est dans la grande salle de
bal du château de maisons une salle qui
a été décoré au 19e siècle avec un
certain nombre de tableaux ici de
paysages italiens
l'objectif ça va être de comprendre le
point commun entre ces différents
tableaux une déambulation de deux heures
préparé à l'occasion de la semaine de la
langue française et de la francophonie
le château il participe pour la première
fois elle nous c'est aussi toujours
l'objectif de faire découvrir le château
au trône en est de pouvoir aussi amener
faire venir un public différent ou un
public qui ne vient pas nécessairement
habituellement au château dis-moi dix
mots et à destination des familles et
des personnes en cours d'alphabétisation
ou d'apprentissage du français
pas besoin d'ouvrir son dictionnaire
pour réviser il faudra juste à voir les
sens en éveil pour vos agendas si vous
êtes intéressés par cette semaine
de la langue française quelques
rendez-vous dans les yvelines au château
de versailles vous pourrez explorer le
chat le réseau hydraulique en compagnie
des fontes aînés ont participé à un
atelier calligrammes au domaine de marly
c'est une visite guidée des jardins qui
vous attend du côté du musée du jouet à
poissy vos talents d'écriture seront mis
à profit et à maisons-laffitte de
nombreuses animations sont organisées et
un miel une dictée avec trois niveaux de
difficulté pour ne rien rater des
rendez-vous direction sur le site
internet de l'événement
un dernier rendez vous avant de quitter
le département des yvelines mardi 17
mars prochain c'est une nouvelle édition
de sensations scène qui était proposé
deux heures d'émission live auquel vous
pouvez assister pour cette nouvelle
édition
tony bastian le dj bulls team 6 et le
groupe chiche ailleurs et
l'exhibitionniste rend hommage à
christian louboutin
en trente ans il est devenu un des
créateurs de mode les plus connus au
monde ne palais de la porte dorée vous
invite à voyager dans l'univers des
louboutin un sujet devient grand paris
glamour décontracté ou sophistiquée
exhibitionniste exposé près de 30 ans de
semelles rouges aussi élégante que
surprenante
son créateur christian louboutin a
habillé l'été les plus célèbres du monde
rihanna kobe bryant mika et même barbie
en façonnant la chaussure telle une
sculpture louboutin a su redonner une
visibilité à l'art du soulier quand on
pense à christian louboutin au tout
début parce qu'aujourd'hui on voit
christian louboutin comme étant une
signature très aboutie du monde de la
mode se rappeler que christian louboutin
a commencé comme un bricoleur génial
dans sa chambre créant des souliers
extraordinaire recouverte de canettes de
bière des boîtes de sardines donc c'est
aussi toute cette créativité qu'il avait
dès le départ et qu'il a su prolonger
aujourd'hui maintenant qu'il peut aussi
avoir accès à des matériaux
exceptionnelle des matériaux issus des
arts du spectacle et des arts décoratifs
strass plumes pellicule perles et
broderies ornent ses créations atypiques
derrière ses souliers se cache un
travail colossal en atelier auquel
christian louboutin a voulu rendre
hommage
c'est quelque chose qui pour lui était
très important dans l'exposition de
montrer un peu le backstage tout ce qui
se passe derrière les métiers comment on
dessine
comment choisis quel matériau choisir
l'exhibitionniste expose aussi les
artistes qui ont inspiré christian du
butin comme le cinéaste david lynch avec
il ici une collaboration extraordinaire
en 2007 un travail présenté dans cette
salle réservée à un public averti
tous les deux s'amusent à faire une
exposition autour du fétichisme à la
fois avec des créations de christian et
en même temps des photographies mises en
scène par david lynch et christian
louboutin sur la question justement de
ce qu'est le soulier en termes
d'objectifs schiste voilà c'est quelque
chose qui pour lui était très important
c'est de ne pas avoir une exposition
égocentrique et purement rétrospective
mais aussi que l'on peut avoir plusieurs
vies donc à successives mais en même
temps quand on est un créateur une
exposition monumentale à la fois
poétique et pédagogique est stupéfiante
vous avez jusqu'au 26 juillet 2020 pour
voyager dans le cabinet des curiosités
de christian louboutin c'est la fin de
ce set 8 loisirs merci de nous avoir
suivi on se retrouve jeudi prochain pour
de nouvelles idées sorties
[Musique]
m